les inégalités sont un important coût
social dans les pays plus égalitaire on
a tendance à observer plus grand accès
l'éducation une plus grande espérance de
vie et la majorité des gens se
retrouvent en meilleure situation
financière que dans les pays qui sont
moins égalitaire alors ce que je vous
montre ici c'est une relation que le
degré d'inégalité l'espérance de vie
à titre d'exemple et pouvait voir que
plus les inégalités augmentent plus
l'espérance de vie diminue
je prends la peine de vous parler de ça
parce qu'on a souvent tendance à penser
aux inégalités comme si c'était une
oeuvre de charité
c'était quelque chose qui n'affectait
pas monsieur ou madame tout le monde et
qu'on pouvait en quelque sorte laissé
pour compte ou bien pensants ou à ceux
qui cherchent faire beau 9 rebonds
images sans vraiment considérer les
différentes ramifications que ça pouvait
avoir
c'est pas tout à fait ça en fait les
inégalités ou se soucier des inégalités
réduire les inégalités
c'est une bonne façon d'éviter le trafic
on sent très bien l'histoire nous
enseigne que nous avons du contrôle sur
ces changements-là sur les inégalités on
peut le faire au premier chef à travers
nos institutions publiques ou d'autres
institutions donc on peut penser
évidemment aux gouvernements aux
différents programmes sociaux qu'on met
en place et plus particulièrement aux
taxes et aux impôts
alors aujourd'hui on va parler des
inégalités vous l'aurez compris mais on
va parler comment on peut affecter la
société comment affecter les inégalités
à travers les taxes et les impôts pour
le faire j'ai besoin de farm and
academic un peu de vous introduire deux
concepts donc c'est les deux choses que
j'aurais besoin de retenir pour qu'on
fasse la conversation ensemble et c'est
là que vous allez avoir besoin d'un
petit peu attention
mettre de côté votre déjeuner et de
regarder ce qu'on de ceux dont on
reparle le premier concert c'est le
concept d'équité
donc c'est la dimension de gauche de la
taxation penser à l'économie comme une
tare et l'ict et on va dire qu'une taxe
et plus équitable qu'une autre
si elle permet de bien redistribuer le
revenu de redistribuer le revenu en des
parts égales donc on va dire qu'une taxe
et plus équitable plus notre sel permet
d'arriver à une société plus égalitaire
ans quelle que soit donc un bel exemple
de taxe équitable c'est l'impôt sur le
revenu l'impôt sur le revenu et
progresser il augmente avec les revenus
qu'on garde et ce faisant les gens qui
ont des revenus plus élevés ont une plus
grande contribution à faire ce qui fait
en sorte que le revenu net le revenu
disponible est plus proche serait et
réduit des gens qui ont des revenus plus
faibles et donc ça contribue à augmenter
limité à travers l'économie
le deuxième concert c'est le concept
d'efficacité donc l'efficacité c'est la
dimension de droit de la taxation
c'est ce qui fait en sorte qu'on peut
prélever un certain montant l'argent en
ayant le moins d'incidence possible sur
la taille de la ta alors ici on ne se
préoccupe préoccupe pas de comment la
tarte est répartie mais vraiment de sa
taille est ce qu'on veut plus d'argent
dans l'économie où est-ce qu'on en a
moins alors on va dire qu'une taxe est
plus efficace qu'une eau si elle permet
de prélever un même montant d'argent
sans trop réduire la taille de la terre
ou inversement pour un montant une
réduction de tarbes donner une réduction
de la taille de l'économie
on va être capable d'aller chercher un
plus grand montant d'argent pour
financer par exemple des programmes
sociaux donc équité et efficacité
idéalement on aimerait une taxe qui est
à la fois efficaces une taxe est à la
fois équitable un exemple de taxes qui
est efficace pour fixer les idées et les
idées c'est une taxe sur l'essence alors
la société étant ce qu'elle est nos
comportements ne changent que très peu
quand le prix de l'essence augmente ou
diminue pourquoi on doit se rendre au
travail font l'épicerie instruite et
donc lorsqu'on augmente le prix de
l'essence à travers une taxe on change
très peu nos comportements on ne reste
pas la maison contre une au travail on
compte 9 à nos activités
ce qui fait que ça ne réduit que de très
peu la taille de la terre dans une taxe
qui 13
das si vous êtes au pouvoir si vous êtes
le ministre des finances où le premier
ministre vous avez la responsabilité de
faire du design fiscal à dire de choisir
la politique fiscale comment on va
prélever ces revenus là et il y à des
arbitrages politiques à faire entre
l'équité et l'efficacité
alors par exemple vous pourriez très
bien diminuer les impôts et augmenter la
taxe sur l'essence
ce faisant vous diminuerez l'équité vous
vous rendriez la société moins
égalitaire mais vous rendriez prendrait
le système fiscal la taxation plus
efficaces donc n'auriez plus d'argent
pour vous seriez capable d'augmenter la
taille de la table pour un montant
d'argent donnée financé par le
gouvernement
impossible de faire ces choix là sans
valeur politique alors évident vous êtes
à gauche d'aller prenant préféré parler
de redistribution de la richesse de
justice sociale
vous êtes à droite vous allez préférer
dire ben non on va en même temps on va
faire croître l'économie
on va essayer de heurter le moins
possible les revenus générés et est
stricte et donc le débat politique
demeure entier sur l'arbitrage à faire
entre ces deux dimensions de la taxation
ceci dit et c'est l'exercice que je vous
propose de faire aujourd'hui
il y a moyen d'avoir une discussion
cohérent intelligent mesuré sur ses
arbitrages à faire là je suis fatigué de
voir les débats publics où on ne fait
que parler de baisser les impôts pour en
mettre plus dans nos poches ou
d'augmenter les impôts parce qu'il faut
taxer les riches parce qu'on sait bien
les régions de l'argent et sans avoir de
réflexion sur l'impact que peut avoir la
politique fiscale sur nos vies alors
aujourd'hui c'est l'exercice qu'on va
faire on va jouer au ministre des
finances
on va le faire avec une simulation
donc on va se permettre de mettre
l'économie du québec dans un laboratoire
et on va jouer avec les taxes on va le
faire en mesurant les inégalités et pour
les mesures et des ça prend du
quantitatif alors ça nous prend un
indice un peu comme un indice boursier
un indice boursier quand ça augmente
ben on sait ce que ça veut dire
l'économie va mieux quand ça diminue
c'est un peu la même chose de colombie
va mal mais là c'est la même chose avec
les inégalités donc quand l'indicé
augmente il y a plus d'inégalités et
quand l' indice diminuent les inégalités
diminuent alors ici on a un beau graf et
vous pouvez le voir plus et vert pâle
plus l'indicé est faible et moins le
pays qui est ciblé par ce graphique là
est victime ou à des inégalités
inversement plus et rouge plus et foncez
plus il ya des gags d'inégalités pardon
dans ce pays alors c'est simple ça monte
ça descend les inégalités mon les
inégalités décembre alors premier
exercice
la première chose qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va fixer le montant de d'argent
qu'on est prêt à sacrifier en production
économique pour réduire les inégalités
donc on veut si on veut on va se fixer
pour les besoins de la conversation va
dire on reprendre un milliard de dollars
du pib l'activité économique
puis on veut le sacrifier pour s'en
servir à travers la taxation
ça peut être plus ça peut être moins
vous êtes à gauche à droite on choisir
le montant de choisir un autre montant
mais c'est pour fixer les idées qu'on
poursuivre la conversation en quête pour
cent si la valeur de base de lundi donc
si les inégalités en ce moment qui
prévalent au québec mais dans ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va prendre trois
taxes on va les augmenter de manière à
ce que justement on atteigne cette
réduction de 1 milliard de dollars
d'activité économique qu'on va voir
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec ce
qu'elle bout de chemin on peut faire
avec cette augmentation de taxes là pour
aller jouer dans les inégalités en
première premier exercice de taxation on
va regarder la taxe sur le capital
la taxe sur le capital si vous
connaissez seule pensée marxiste
c'est la taxe qui vise les propriétaires
d'usinés donc pas sucre
ceux qui ont vraiment assez d'argent qui
tirent leurs revenus du marché des
marchés boursiers qui possède les
industries et c'est donc une taxe de par
sa nature président alpha dire qu'elle
va vraiment chercheurs redistribuer le
revenu
elle va être très redistributive ceci
dit c'est une taxe qui est inefficace
pourquoi elle est inefficace parce
qu'elle d un site à investir et à
augmenter la capacité productive dans
l'économie donc évidemment si on vous
taxe pour construire des usines vous
allez vouloir construire - dix usines se
faisant moins du zen - de production
plus petite taille de temps alors ce
pour ce milliards de réductions de dans
l'économie on est capable d'aller
chercher 300 millions de dollars dont 30
sous par dollars avec cette augmentation
de taxes là parce que la taxe est
équitable relativement équitable on est
capable de faire passer les inégalités
de 34% à 32 pour ça donc elle est
équitable en soi mais elle va chercher
très peu d'argent et ce montant l'argent
là qu'on utilise pour redistribuer aux
plus pauvres est relativement faibles
dont 300 millions c'est pas beaucoup
d'argent
enfin la première sur l'asie la deuxième
simulation c'est la taxe devant donc la
tvq ou la tps ce que vous payez en taxes
sur vos dépenses d'épicerie
quand vous allez au cinéma ou au
restaurant alors on augmente la taxe de
vente et vous voyez que pour cette même
réduction de 1 milliard qu'on s'est
fixés pour faire la conversation on est
capable d'aller chercher 800 millions de
dollars
beaucoup plus efficace ceci dit c'est
une taxe qui relativement inéquitable
pourquoi parce que la consommation en
proportion du revenu est beaucoup plus
élevé chez les gens qui ont des revenus
plus faibles
ce faisant on va chercher plus de
revenus en proportion chez les gens à
plus faibles revenus et donc l'effet du
cas le caractère relativement
inéquitable de la taxation combiné avec
son inefficacité donc les 800 millions
qu'on peut redistribuer nous permettre
d'amener les inégalités de 34% à prendre
pour ça voyez dans la taxe sur le
capital la taxe marxisme nous permet de
réduire les inégalités davantage même si
on va chercher - dreux
troisième point la deuxième situation
trois installations
on va regarder l'impôt sur le revenu
impôt sur le revenu vous connaissez ça
vous fait votre déclaration d'impôts ça
vise les travailleurs si ce que vous
devez contribuer à travers les
différents taux progressif c'est une
taxe relativement efficace au sens
qu'elle est plus efficace que la taxe
sur le capital
voyons pas les chercher 600 millions de
dollars au lieu de 300 millions $ mais
elle est moins efficace que la taxe de
vente ou la taxe à la consommation
la raison étant que lorsqu'on taxent le
travail les gens sont incités à moins
travailler lorsqu'ils travaillent moins
on réduit la taille de la terre donc
moins moins efficace par contre une taxe
qui est très équitable souvenez on parle
d'augmenter la contribution en fonction
du revenu et donc l'effet d'équité de la
taxe en elle-même nous permet d'aller
chercher une réduction des inégalités de
34 % à 30 %
bref j'ai tenu à vous montrer trois
simulations très très 5 vous inciter à
réfléchir en fait que lorsqu'on vous
présente des réformes fiscales
il y a des dimensions importantes il y a
des effets importants qui ont décidant d
incidence sur nos vies qui ont des coûts
sociaux qui ont des répercussions sur la
société et qu'il ya des différents
mécanismes l'équité et l'efficacité qui
nous permettent d'atteindre ces
objectifs là pour justement par exemple
réduire ici les inégalités alors
j'espère dans le débat public la
prochaine fois vous entendre une
proposition une réforme fiscale vous
aurez en mesure un certain bagage je
serai capable de vous dire on est ce que
c'est une taxe équitable est une taxe
plus équitable d'une autre est ce
qu'elle est efficace ou non
plutôt que de vous laisser discourir sur
la question de est-ce que c'est plus
d'argent dans les poches ou non mais
surtout de vous rappeler qu'en matière
de réduction des inégalités
ce ne sont pas toutes les taxes sont
égales